un an encore jean hugues ratenon était
militant associatif payés au smic élu au
mois de juin député de la 5e
circonscription il a rejoint jean luc
mélenchon et son parti la france
insoumise et depuis près d'un an
il découvre les ors de la république et
le fonctionnement de l'assemblée
nationale à paris jean marc collienne et
laurent figon l'ont suivi dans lors
d'une journée est très longue regardez
à l'heure des laveurs de vitres devant
les bureaux de l'assemblée nationale
le jour est à peine levé jean hugues
ratenon arrive de l'aéroport d'orly
il est 7h30 et jean hugues ratenon
rejoint ses bureaux au deuxième étage de
cette annexe de l'assemblée nationale
c'est votre maison va parler ça c'est
votre maison à cause de ça ces mots mon
bureau et puis le soir nous at il veut
voir la solide
attention ça passe et là c'est lui jean
hugues ratenon a dû s'habituer à cette
nouvelle ville et notamment à la fatigue
des voyages raisonnement suler c'est
comme un voyage en économie en classe
troisième
c'est impossible si tu voyages corps mon
cas ce qu'ont faut bien on casse plus
que kung fu ton qu'on ne suis pas c est
possible dans les séries mais pas si
vous devez voyage hors du coup mais
malgré parfois ainsi me rappelle une
fois au début même comment la voyage
dahir menad nous notre monde il ya des
morceaux fait lens a dit non et pas de
place là à dire qu'on balaye devant là
bas ou des lieux de vacances au vert et
c'est là où on voit mal à réaliser que
quand moi me faisais quelque chose
c'était le député a juste le temps de
repasser sa chemise
ensuite une petite douche qu'une demi
heure plus tard nous retrouvons jean
hugues ratenon en compagnie de son
collaborateur parlementaire tunisie se
plaît
le de la commission alors que les
travaux de l'assemblée nationale ont
déjà commencé les deux hommes font le
point sur le programme de la journée
ça c'est pour aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
après iata demain demain mercredi c'est
ça premier rendez vous ce matin 9h30
jean hugues ratenon rejoint l'assemblée
nationale de l'autre côté de la rue tout
ça où tu es connais pas mais qui nous
guide dans les salles du palais bourbon
là on est on arrive
juste en la salle
la personne a indiqué mme kroes
les journalistes sont regroupés
pour imaginer un jour où on retrouve ici
voilà le genre hugues ratenon possible
pour les intimes et appelle à margaux
d'antipatinage et rodez bras panon
présentement ici et jamais je n'aurais
pensé que député
noré net dans un car à tiques qui
appelle l'algérie des mais on se
rappelle qu'en japon justement ce côté
la marmaille la cour arriver là ça
voulait faire ça remet les fier parce
que maman et la cour
né d'un père planteurs que l'était aussi
de militants à la sogepe avec les
planteurs la lutte était difficile à
l'époque où la ville était difficile de
travail le matin pour manger le soir et
des fois en ce moment
tu es partage mange avec toutes ses
enfants elle avait pour ainsi qu elle ya
quelques mois encore tu écoutes métier
mène à quelques mois mon été
responsables d'associations étaient mal
à venti salaires commente hélène médigue
ls 1142 groupe à l'époque à l'époque
le cheval
antibes assez de salles et de
députés c'est-à-dire 5000 euros nets
c'est pas ça le plus important
j'ai vu mouiller 11 heures c'est l'heure
de la réunion des députés de la france
insoumise mélenchon rifains corbières
mais également le député européen
younous omarjee font le tour de
l'actualité
la blessure l'a fait évidemment suivi
nous jean hugues ratenon est invité à
prendre la parole pour évoquer une
proposition de loi visant à interdire
les expulsions locatives
sans solution de relogement c'est une
proposition de du mouvement la france
assume ce qu'on me demande de de
présenter bus mais dans l'immédiat
les députés de la france a soumises
décidé d'improviser et d'aller sur le
terrain soutenir les cheminots en grève
pour pas de course
il s'engouffre dans le métro et entre
deux stations jean hugues ratenon se
confie députés
les deux-tiers de la vie privée
disons que c'est ça le plus dur c'est
pas la ville des piquets l'assemblée
nationale c'est la vie de député
pour ces prochains
ça c'est difficile ils sont gentils ne
disent rien et on sort qu'il ya un
problème
il ya une cassure
pourquoi changer
jean lui arriver à la gare de l'est
jean hugues ratenon se laisse gagner par
l'ambiance de la manifestation et par
une certaine euphorie révolutionnaire du
coup il en oublie sans doute qu'il a un
micro explosia le feu par un peu toi ça
suppose ya le feu
oui je la plus que je veux
pendant 10 minutes jean luc mélenchon
fait le show au milieu des cheminots et
des dizaines de journalistes qui se
passe autour de lui puis la petite
troupe reprend le métro sous quelques
huées
car la séance va reprendre à l'assemblée
nationale la parole est un monsieur
françois ruffin un contrôleur dans le
train me disait vous vous connaissez la
blague de coluche
les technocrates si on leur donnait le
sahara dans cinq ans il faudrait qu'ils
achètent du sable ailleurs jean hugues
ratenon seul député réunionnais présents
ce jour-là interviendra pour sa part
plus tard ce soir
avant cela il aura improvisé une réunion
de travail avec son collaborateur dans
un coin du palais bourbon et assister à
une réunion de la commission des
affaires sociales toute une journée de
réunions de rencontre et après avoir
pris le temps d'aller dîner
c'est maintenant à son tour de prendre
la parole dans mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre en 2015 réaliser
une étude sur le coût de la vie ont en
outre mer il est alors 22h30 et il ne
reste plus qu'une cinquantaine de
députés dans l'hémicycle pour entendre
le député réunionnais reprendre son
vieux combat contre la vie chère compte
faire le gouvernement
cette nuit là jean hugues ratenon
restera sur les bancs de l'assemblée
jusqu'à une heure du matin